every Navy ship in submarine is had its
design tested here at the Naval Surface
Warfare centers Carderock division
engineers recreate to scale hazards and
conditions a ship could face at sea
computer models are used to break the
flow of wind and water high-speed
cameras capture underwater explosions to
understand the impact on vessels 3d
printers have been used for over a
decade a design an enormous wave for
when a hurricane for seas to test
maneuverability and seaworthiness we're
basically a technical adviser for the
Navy for home mechanical and electrical
engineering for the Navy's ships
submarines combatant craft and unmanned
vehicles but the highlight of the campus
is the 3200 foot long David Taylor model
Basin one of the largest facilities of
its kind in the world the craft was
trimmed with weights to give it the
right bounce the Navy opened the basin
in 1940 after finding the Bethesda
Maryland site had the solid bedrock to
support the massive pools access to
water and close proximity to Navy's
Washington offices the key ingredient is
industry government partnership we work
with our industry partners to develop
different aspects of using advanced
computational tools to develop computer
models on ships and in addition we also
develop physical models of ships with
the scale-model ships of the real size
ship Lockheed Martin Northrop Grumman
General Dynamics Huntington Ingalls and
Raytheon used the unique facility and
its specialized consultants we have
these work for private parties
agreements in which industry can come in
and work with our engineers in order to
conduct different types of testing or
experimentation that's required to
advance or develop our Navy ship design
every two years the basin hosts the
international human powered submarine
races to challenge and inspire high
school and college kids in science and
engineering they had a look at
hydrodynamics they had a look at
buoyancy and stability and weights they
had a look at systems engineering a
whole mariya different types of real
world design challenges those students
may not come up with the ship of the
future every time chances are the Navy's
next war
ship will sail here in the Maryland
suburbs or it ever reaches the sea